this boat was once musa barcama's only
source of income a trader from chad he
says he used to transport goods between
his country and nigeria through lake
chad now he only comes to check on it
and clear out water that has seeped in
trading between here and nigeria is the
only job i know then boko haram came
from nigeria and raided our village
killing three people and injuring others
i used my boat to get people out of the
village and came here
now have no work because i can't
transport goods to the nigerian side of
the lake anymore
lake chad is a fresh water source for
millions of people in nigeria niger chad
and cameroon all of which surround the
lake it's also a source of livelihood
for hundreds of thousands chadian
traders used to transport goods on boats
to nigeria many here say it was more
cost effective and fishermen rely on the
lake to supply local markets but since
2015 boko haram violence in northeastern
nigeria has spilled over the border to
the lakeside villages that surround it
authorities were forced to close the
borders in response
many here say that's caused a disruption
in the market and led to increase in
prices of goods
the attacks by boko haram have
restricted trade between countries
surrounding lake chad and limited areas
for fishermen to fission so that's also
put a strain on the local economy the
violence has also changed the pattern of
movement between countries surrounding
the lake where people once moved freely
now hundreds of thousands have been
forced to leave to escape the attacks
the shores of the lake here on the
chadian side was one spare now dozens of
houses have been built for those
displaced by boko haram bukaye and his
family are some of those who had to flee
from king galem island in chat to the
shore of the lake
i used to work back home in my village
as a farmer but because of attacks by
boko haram i've been displaced my
village and now i have no job they stole
all my belongings when they're raided
about 6 000 chadian soldiers have been
deployed on the lake to deal with the
threat local authorities say they're
working with aid organizations to help
those who have been displaced and reopen
crucial trade routes
i think the security situation is now
stable but up to now the route between
nigeria and chat can't be opened because
we can't guarantee security we need to
continue combing the lake in places that
traders usually move around to guarantee
their safety the nigerian authorities
and i are working on it and we hope to
succeed in the coming months
but until the routes are safe again musa
says his boat will remain on shore he
hopes the authorities will be able to
end boko haram's attack soon so that he
can once again earn a living hiba morgan
al-jazeera lake chad